[Music]
actually it's Wednesday but I did get 49
people to say hello to you at VidCon
which isn't nothing so Hank we're just
back from VidCon and for your
edification I have compiled my top 10
VidCon moments number 10 dancing to the
all-caps song don't unplug me I think as
you know I can't dance but I am very
passionate about it same way I felt
about French kissing in high school
number nine Mika kitties Velociraptor
move Oh scary but also alluring eight
Dan Brown's announcement of Dan 3.0 for
one year
I am very literally put in complete
control of my life in your hands I think
I think Dan 3.0 would be a fascinating
social experiment although I fear that
if we did it people would just make us
put unicorns on our head all the time
number seven hi I'm Ron asked me to
dress up as a turkey for his big musical
production and I was pulling on the
turkey costume and I was like Ron that's
fun I'm happy to do it but I don't know
am I supposed to dance am I supposed to
get on stage when you want whereupon he
turned to a guy dressed as Batman
pointed at him and said Batman I'm gonna
need you to be a leader in this
situation number six Hanks singing on
stage with you for the first and last
time in my life
[Music]
doesn't matter if Sonia
[Applause]
number five mass hub at the nerdfighter
gathering involving hundreds of
nerdfighters for I suppose at this point
I should be used to it but say Frank
gave the most astonishingly brilliant
keynote address I think I have ever
heard
reminding us that we don't make or watch
videos for money or subscribers or views
but because we want to feel what it's
like to be other people and let others
feel what it's like to be us number
three just how nice everyone was I mean
given the fact that youtubers are mostly
introverted nerdy people who like to
spend their free time with editing
software everyone was incredibly nice
everyone hung out famous people didn't
act like they were famous and the whole
vibe of the event was so wonderfully
supportive and collaborative number two
two words double rainbow the Gregory
Brothers have auto-tune the news singing
a song they had written mere hours
before this is the song that goes out to
all the rainbows
[Applause]
also the ladies mostly the rain
and number one seeing my little brother
sing about particle physics in front of
a thousand people who loved every second
of it important is a fundamental
instance you went to a matter observed
in 1968 thirteenth elector scattered and
found that protons are more complexed
and we thought we thought they were
solid particles but they are not
nerdfighters Hank thank you for all the
thousands of hours you spent making
VidCon as awesome as it was it felt like
my favorite parts of the internet
existed in real life for three whole
days nerdfighters if you were at VidCon
whether in real life or on livestream
please let us know what your favorite
parts of the conference were and let us
know if ank is crazy enough to do this
whole thing again
who and what you'd like to see at VidCon
2011 so Hank thanks again and I will see
aggression I'm happy for you now the way
you finished but the vlogbrothers have
one of the most subscribed youtube
channels of all time that's right the
blog but that just broke into the top
100 most subscribed thank you all for
subscribing for Tigger thanks to
raywilliamjohnson Charlie's so cool like
and Myka kitty but thanks to everybody
you're so awesome Hank I'll see you on
Friday